[Music]
so james your laces book is on nihilism
um the philosophy that claims life is
meaningless most people see this as a
bad thing but you don't tell us why it's
okay for life to have no meaning well
the idea of a meaning of life is of a
grand evaluative context like you know
master plan for the human race well if
there's one of those
then it could be good or it could be bad
because it's an evaluation right you're
taking a certain state of affairs and
you're saying it's good or bad in some
way if there isn't one of those contexts
then it can't be bad and it can't be
good either all it can be is a fact a
fact about reality so i think that's uh
the problem that people have seen in
nihilism and this has gone on for a very
long time now i mean people first
started talking about nihilism in you
know the german romantic
um 179 1790s
the terminology meaning of life and
nihilism come in around the same time
and it's always you know the meaning of
life is good nihilism is bad okay
um
but that presupposes the religious
context and you see that from the very
first use of of the word it's like you
know we'll assume there's this big
evaluative context you know and that's
what makes your life good living
according to god's plan or something so
clearly somebody who turns their back on
that who doesn't follow god's plan is
terrible you know you don't turn your
back on on god's purposes right so
annihilus is terrible but if you think
that the knights is actually rejecting
that context then it can't be bad
um it only looks bad if you look at it
from the context which the nihilist is
is actually rejecting so so it's
rejecting the idea that there's an
externally imposed meaning on life by
some deity or kind of uh transcendental
sort of being that that's right so i
mean
so what so i i mean i don't think that
that that's true many people in the
world
most people in the world have religious
beliefs and do believe this in a
valuative context i've got no problem
with that whatsoever but the problem
i have is people just presupposing
there's something bad about nihilism
because that seems to be
a mistake as far as i'm concerned and
and and then the other thing i'm opposed
to i mean i don't like being opposed to
things right but i i i feel nihilism is
so badly understood it's um
it's
that idea that arises from nature which
is that nihilism is a problem for
atheists because you know without god to
create the meaning we have to create the
meaning and i think that's an even worse
idea in many ways
so so it it isn't then that without an
objective meaning
we're afraid to create our own meanings
as it were and impose impose our own
meanings unto unto life it's not it's
not a liberating thought necessarily
well if that's true then it was always
true um and in a sense in a very obvious
sense right we are free to create our
own meanings okay so i've got
certain aims at the moment and i try and
pursue them you know i'm trying to say
something reasonably sensible in this
interview etc right okay and then later
on i'll have aims of going and buying a
beer and you know enjoying myself and
then getting home and you know we have
these projects and they lead into wider
projects right throughout life so yeah i
mean we do create meaning but the
problem is if you try and make that
creation of meaning a substitute for the
old religious idea of a meaning of life
then you have to pick on one meaning and
if you know and that's baseless because
there are so many different meanings and
the meanings change all the time as as
we move through our lives so you know
and then if you try and make it a
substitute for the old religious idea
you're going to have to say you know you
get the sort of disagreement which you
see among philosophers you know some
think that meaning is this something
that meaning isn't
and you know if you're going to have
that kind of meaning which we're making
then you have graduations of it so maybe
we'll work out that my life is more
meaningless meaningful than yours or
vice versa you know we're judging people
um a baseless way of judging people what
about the context of ancient greek
philosophy so a lot of philosophy
in plato in aristotle was trying to
establish
what the best way to deliver life is
what a good life is if you like um was
that an attempt in a way to find the
meaning of life and if so does that mean
a lot of that philosophy was a kind of
waste of time no i don't think so at all
i i think they had a broader conception
of ethics than we do
today
um but i think ultimately all of those
things have got to be considered as
proposals i mean they had a metaphysics
that backed it up but i wouldn't call
that a meaning of
life a grand evaluative context so they
thought that reality i mean certainly in
aristotle's case was tediological in
some sense i don't
accept anything like that myself
but they were trying to work out what
the good life for human beings were i
mean i approve of that kind of thing
what happens in contemporary debates it
seems to me is is um you know when
people say there's a difference between
ethically good
and meaning and they see meaning as
something distinct which they've
discovered they've just they're just
broadening a conception of ethics um
you know because the meaning of full
life is always supposed to be a good
life
um
you know just having a significant life
isn't supposed to be good enough for
some people but you know
how do you just how do you determine
which bid is supposed to make it
meaningful i mean an ethically good life
i think that's an easier concept to
understand and you know
right before the greeks were those two
things running together sort of an
ethically good life and a good life for
someone to live is it for like a medium
life aristotle gives you a conception of
a good life for a human being you know
this this is a good life for a plant or
a cat or something like that and this is
a good life for a human being that's
that's the way
in which they thought i to me those are
always proposals which we can try
you know that might be useful for for
our lives i mean there's a lot of things
like this in the 20th century you get
existentialists trying to revive that
kind of conception you know live in an
existentially free way choose what
you're going to do next maybe that'll
work for some people maybe it won't work
for some people i i just see them as
proposals i don't think the nature of
reality you know if you think in a
meaning of life type way you might think
the nature of reality dictates that and
i think that's a mistake i think these
are proposals that might work for some
people and might not work for others
so one of the philosophies that sort of
liberated us from this kind of
gorge uh created world a world that's
given meaning by an external being was
materialism
uh and you know it sort of influenced
humanity both scientifically and
philosophically and socially
but
you argue that materialism has now also
kind of enslaved us so it liberated us
from that picture but it has enslaved us
in a different kind of picture
especially when it comes to the idea of
like progress and technological
advancement
what's
what's wrong with that picture what's
wrong with materialism how has it gone
bad as it were i don't think it's well i
don't think it's true for a start um you
know the claim of materialism i think
must be false given the nature of human
experience etc and the last 70 80 years
attempts to try and say that it's
something material or try and deny that
it exists
yeah i think the dissatisfaction is
getting pretty obvious with that picture
now so i think it's false and it's a
very old picture
but i don't think it's useful for people
anymore
because if you make experience seem
mystifying or you have doubts about
whether it really exists etc you don't
reflect the way human life
is moving which is towards experience
you know
people are looking at screens more
people are entering into virtual worlds
if you've got philosophy that makes all
that seem problematic it's not really
going to be useful for us in our current
day and age and i think we're going to
need philosophy a lot more than we've
ever needed it in the years to come as
we recreate these problems with this
this technology because i mean we've got
a situation now where
it seems to me that
you know you say out of control well in
a sense it is right i mean when somebody
comes up with a new technology that
complete will change people's lives i
don't really think that we just sort of
accept it and hope it doesn't go wrong
you know you see in
the sort of anxieties people have now
will artificial intelligence be the end
of us you know it's almost like we're
looking out at these meteors coming
towards the earth oh no they're huge
meteors if it hits the earth we're all
going to die but hopefully it will miss
you know there's people making this
stuff um and
i think the human population has become
sort of detached from this we just sort
of thought what were the clever
scientists and technologists produce
next oh dear that's causing social
problems you know people are abusing
social media or you know people have
become addicted to virtual reality they
can't get out of it oh dear we'll have
to deal with that as if as if you know
it wasn't people actually producing this
technology and that you know that
shouldn't be something that politicians
are actually very interested in so
there's a sort of fatalism about it that
it's just it's just happening it's a
process that is unstoppable people often
say this progress is you know you might
as well be against the gravity if you're
against progress it's not something that
can be controlled it's just something
natural yeah that's right but it isn't
it isn't necessarily progress it's just
something new coming along it's like i
call it in my new book uh cetus
technological advance it just continues
and then we deal with what happens
afterwards i think we need some sort of
collective
rational control over that process you
know it needs to enter the democratic
process
philosophy opens people's minds up to
big issues exactly like the
the meaning of life and thinking about
our lives and our reality in a wider
context i think that's exactly what we
need it also has a distinct advantage in
this in today's world of being neither
science nor religion but able to reflect
rationally on both of them you also
don't need any equipment for philosophy
you know anybody can do it it's also
something that people are just naturally
interested in you know small kids are
very interested in philosophical
questions and then they're told not to
ask anymore you know
how did reality come along you know come
about in the first place well nobody
knows
let's just stop
you know that's what we need to live up
i make it compulsory in primary school
yeah
so you you reach back to a very
different philosophical tradition
idealism for finding sort of your way
out of these
dead ends of materialism and
philosophically and socially
uh idealism of course has a very bad rap
in anglophone uh analytic philosophy
people often associated with barclays
philosophy that matter is not real
everything is made of ideas what is
idealism for you there have been lots
and lots of different forms of idealism
in the history of philosophy and after
doing my talk on it this afternoon a lot
of people came up to me and said i
really like i really like the way you're
thinking about it but i'm not sure about
idealism as a title well you know in a
way i'm not sure in the first book i i
didn't call it that i called it the
transcendent hypothesis and the second
book i thought i'd try and time with
tradition i changed the label i didn't
change the theory maybe i still haven't
got the right label for it but but the
idea i think is quite simple to get
across and i could do it
i think the reason it can seem confusing
how matter and experience you know can
possibly exist alongside each other it's
because we're thinking of experience in
a limited way
we think of an experience like a pain or
a tickle or something you can you're
aware of just like you can be aware of a
you know a table or a camera or
something like that okay there it is
there's the pain there's a tickle okay
we think of it as a kind of separate
independent reality like the physical
world and then we try and put the two
together
of course a materialist says only
you know the physical is a independent
reality the jeweler says both the pan
psychiatrist tries to insert the
mental into the physical
but there's another way of thinking
about experiences and that's to think of
it as a context or arena within which
things appear to us right so within my i
mean we it's built into our language
right within my conscious experience
physical things appear to me right
and so do mental things experiential
things tickles appear to me dogs and
cats appear to me tables appear to me
okay the way i see it is whether we go
physical or we go experientially as it
is a matter of explanation
what's appearing to us that's a reality
um conceived within
consciousness right and then the
independent reality is outside of
consciousness so idealism for you as a
way to make better sense of experience
what about other another big topic for
idealism which was freedom do you think
idealism is a way of making sense of how
we can be free
in a material world given that we're
material beings yeah
that's another one i i took on in in
gods and titans yeah i think
um
i think we're free and the um i was
actually surprised when i started
looking into this i um i assumed i would
take a compatibilist line but in the end
i just decided there's no reason to
think determinism is true whatsoever
i started to think it has a lot to do
with astrology and various superstitious
beliefs and looked into the history of
how people started to believe in
determinism so determinism isn't true i
don't think there's any reason to think
we're not free and i i now
i surprised myself five years ago i
didn't think this but now i think that
uh determinism is just a superstition
and uh one final question can you tell
us a little about the way you fuse jazz
with philosophy what do the two have in
common and how do you well you know jazz
bringing the two together my thing since
i was what eleven years old when i first
heard cannonball natalie and then i got
a saxophone and uh i was gonna be a jazz
musician
i went i was into jazz before i even
knew anything about philosophy i went to
america to berkeley college on a
scholarship and that's what i was doing
but then of course i got into philosophy
when i moved down to
london so i've always been doing the two
so reached a certain point in my life i
thought can i combine these in some way
so i i tried to you know
been doing this for years now sort of
like insert some of the philosophy into
the
music by getting actors and singers
together and then
we made an album uh i'm very pleased
with back in 2016 in which we you know i
think it's pretty credible it works as
jazz and it works as philosophy and then
since then i've been trying to do
more and more of it it's hard to do
because it's so unfamiliar so nobody or
nobody will give you a gig but if anyone
wants to give me a gig we are the jazz
philosophy fusion band is available and
they're good they're all professional
musicians apart from me but i'm
professional philosopher so you know
that makes
sense james sartaglia thank you very
much thanks
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas
at iai tv